how's it going bros monies and welcome
welcome welcome to the barbershop
very good yes okay what's your name
that's a great name
now we're gonna shave your face oh god
your face looks oh that's a little close
to the eye let's start trimming don't
worry I'm a trained professional yep yep
that's good
I call that one the reverse Hitler if I
can just yes so how was your day
yes now let's get rid of the mustache
don't worry it's it's totally fine to
have a little bit of my own mustache
it's it's it's it's all good I call this
one the Jesus Christ look at that
sideburn those are more than Wolverine
alright are we just supposed to trim
everything I don't I don't know what I'm
doing here did I miss a spot on your
face no don't worry about it those are
just fashion fashion tingaling's almost
done now just gonna finish up the
sideburns yes and we are done great you
look great now you're ready for your
night out with your fans
could you feel better hey that wasn't a
I mean of course and a yes wow what a
game this one I played before and holy
[ __ ] did it was it buggy all right it
did not work at all but I have faith
that it will work now
it's called diner walk simulator now I'm
going to select my Dino which of course
will be t-rex cat okay here we go
this is a moving ok well this is pretty
underwhelming this is it
oh oh ok
no it's still buggy as [ __ ] let's try
another carrot card because a game about
racing with dinos needs to be played
with a car ok let's let's try that again
here we go the car runs I'll be running
for the meteors this is why cars can
never be extinct because they can outrun
meteors everyone this is my favorite
dinosaur
Oh God is so sexy look at him go
tripping on a [ __ ] Attila I can get a
[ __ ] chatter so what get the camera
with a good one make a movie [ __ ] sake
guys you can't just you can't just make
a game like this did you Oh dick discuss
it just it just goes oh I'm back hi guys
that's good ok I can this is clearly
game is not finished
I know what you're thinking there's no
way in hell that we can out match these
games in terms of quality well I don't
think you bros are 100% ready no offense
I don't think you 100% ready for click
activating that button do you do you
want me to click it are you sure
all right hold my hand
you know what that's weed hold your own
hands because I think you need someone's
hand to hold if you have a pet your mom
just just hold their hand before I click
on this button all right you ready
you're doing okay great
and his name is Josh
and his name is Johnson now I know what
you're thinking
pit-a-pat this game so far have been so
good how do you find all this amazing
games how could he possibly have more
amazing games well have you seen sweet
potato it's a two-player game so I'm
just gonna play with that game
Edgar you'll be a player number two what
the [ __ ] are you on about [ __ ]
look at those [ __ ] net sonic nipples
oh god oh don't get distracted by the
nipples yeah that's right yeah just
trying to pitch game over game over
that was pretty underwhelming the next
game it's another two-player game
actually I'm told now by the producers
that we have a guess to play this game
why don't you come in hello my name is
Michael Michael Jackson everyone Michael
Jackson coming up from the dead so that
was you brought me here to play a game
that's about me Michael Jackson you're
right you're right Michael this game is
about you here we go
how do I move you play with the arrow
buttons there you go you got it Michael
there I'm this one and you can move your
gate there you go
okay well send it down I can change Oh
better take another one do I cap and oh
wow woo oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] [ __ ] you
Michael excuse me
no I'm not gonna actually do it [ __ ] oh
I'm out Jess you've turned into a plane
Oh
your time is out Michael to everyone
Michael Jackson good point
thanks Michael Jackson so much for
coming on the channel I'm the dead
that's a very mature she ate it
I'm going back I'm going back now to the
underworld alright so that was three
three games and pets hope you enjoyed it
Wow keep suggesting me these amazing
games leave a like and enjoy watching
obviously you made it this far so come
on Russ thank you so much I'll see you
in the next one
stay awesome ruff I think old men are
chasing me naked but the music is so
distracting that I barely noticed
you